Hi, let’s talk about the elephant in the
room: the AI models like ChatGPT by setting
8 facts about large language models straight.
These ideas were presented in this paper written
by Sam Bowman, who is an Associate Professor
of Data Science, Linguistics, and Computer
Science at New York University.
Me and Ms. Coffee Bean cannot agree more with
the author here, and we would like to spread
his ideas to a wider public that does not
regularly check arXiv for new scientific papers.
We also added a 9th point at the end, which
is a point that I wish everybody would know
about large language models.
In this video, we will set aside the AI talk
that includes hype or AI doomerism,
we will ignore US Senate hearings for or against
AI regulations.
We’ll just talk for laymen and for professionals
alike about what me, a Coffee Bean and Sam
Bowman here,
would like that everybody in society should
know about large language models like ChatGPT.
But not before we thank Prodigy, the sponsor
of this video.
Prodigy is a script-able and developer friendly
data annotation tool made by the same developers
who created spaCy.
When you're training machine learning models
you need reliable training data and Prodigy
helps you with that.
Prodigy allows you to easily annotate data
for named entity recognition, text categorisation,
span classification ... but also offers interfaces
for computer vision, audio, video, and more.
You can even roll out your own custom interfaces
easily because everything in Prodigy is scriptable
with Python.
Prodigy also just released a new alpha version
that has support for prompt engineering, large
language model features and task routers that
allow you to configure annotator overlap as
well as who gets to annotate each example
in your dataset.
Prodigy really makes it easy to iterate on
your data and this month you can get a personal
license for 10% off using this discount code.
Great, now back to the video!
Today, we want to talk about eight facts everyone
should know about large language models, or
short LLM.
If you do not know exactly what an LLM is,
then think of ChatGPT.
An LLM is trained to complete sentences, so
it is a statistical next-word predictor.
But if you want to know more about how ChatGPT
works, then you may want to check out some
of our previous videos on this.
Okay, here we go with the first fact you need
to know about large language models:
1.
They predictably get more capable with increasing
investment, even without targeted innovation.
The more text an LLM used as training data
and the larger the LLM is (in terms of number
of parameters), the better it does on completing
sentences.
Here we want to stress that to improve the
model, it is not like its training objective
changes or its architecture or anything else
requiring innovation.
To improve the model, all one needs is to
use just more and more of what it already
has: data and parameters.
How do we know this?
Well, from many experiments.
For example, one experiment is presented in
the GPT-4 paper, where they showed how the
language model performance consistently improved
when increasing the computation used to train
it by 10,000,000,000× (10 billion) times
from a small prototype system to GPT-4.
One should think about what this means: GPT-3
used 20,000x more compute to train than GPT-2.
So, more data and more parameters make better
models at their training task of completing
unfinished text.
Sounds intuitive, you would say, but this
gets us to the second point here:
2.
Many important LLM behaviors emerge unpredictably
as a byproduct of increasing investment.
This means that these models that are being
trained on completing unfinished text, are
also getting better at other tasks, such as
arithmetic.
Yes, to predict the result of 2+2 is also
a completion of unfinished text, but we have
very hard requirements of how to complete
this text, since only one answer is correct.
When measuring with corresponding task metrics
how well an LLM does in arithmetic or word
unscrambling or other tasks, they go from
being complete idiots on that task to being
really good at them while just increasing
their compute and size.
It’s problematic that with these task metrics,
it is not easy to predict when the genius
spark happens: whether the model figures out
the task solution at 10 sextillion FLOPs (a
measure for computation) or at a septillion,
because the curves here are nonlinear and
it’s like the model is saying: “I cannot
do it” and then, “I did it!”
Recent research shows that these nonlinear
curves can follow more linear trends
if we measure task performance with better
metrics, but it is not easy to do so, because
most of metrics are just accuracy based and
count in a black or white fashion the fraction
of examples the model got right.
Also, a reason for unpredictability here is
the effect of in-context learning: For few-shot
in-context learning, it means that one first
gives the LLM some solved examples in the
input and only then asks the model to solve
the next example of interest.
Other ways of making the model learn in context
is to explain in the input the rules of a
game, then it could play the game (perhaps
better than your coffee beans!).
Such unexpected properties like in-context
learning, made it very difficult for experts
to predict how LLMs would improve over the
years.
In-context learning and all the other task-specific
abilities, like programming abilities or arithmetic,
are a counterintuitive byproduct from a fancy
autocomplete, so from a model that was just
trained to guess the next word.
And do you know what these fancy autocompletes
can also do?
3.
They often appear to learn and use representations
of the outside world.
Wow, really?
I mean, [stochastic parrots], these models
have just seen just text and not the real
world and still, what they understand about
the real world is impressive: LLMs do sometimes
show that they have a “mental model” of
what they are talking about.
They can sometimes give instructions on how
to draw an object they invented!
Or, we cite “Models that are trained to
play board games from descriptions of individual
game moves, without ever seeing a full depiction
of the game board, learn internal representations
of the state of the board at each turn (Li
et al., 2023).”
They also surprise us with common sense from
time to time, like that my chair cannot be
dry and wet simultaneously or that if I spilled
a glass of water, the surface gets wet.
It is not always that they show common sense
of course, but it is more common sense than
initially expected from LLMs which are nothing
but statistical next-word predictors.
Then it would be great if we had a reliable
way to steer them towards producing common
sense or true facts, right?
It would be indeed cool, but:
4.
There are no reliable techniques for steering
the behavior of LLMs.
There are some ways to influence what the
LLM produces after it finished its training
on autocompleting sentences.
One way is prompting, so wording the question
such that the right answer becomes more probable.
Supervised fine-tuning is further training
the model to match high quality human demonstrations
on a task.
Then there is Reinforcement learning from
human feedback, or short RLHF.
If interested in this, check out previous
videos on this.
In a nutshell, RLHF is puppy training: the
model gets a reward for good answers to make
it learn good behavior and new tricks.
But these three methods, still do not make
it perfect and LLMs can still lie and be biased.
Even worse, RLHF endorses some behavior, such
as sycophancy (fancy term for a behavior where
they flatter you even in your misconceptions)
or sandbagging, where it endorses your misconceptions
if you appear to be less educated.
If you push back on ChatGPT, it's likely to
fold and say you're right.
Not because its answer was wrong, but because
it wants you to be happy.
This makes sense, since with RLHF, it was
trained to be a friendly, helpful, chat assistant.
But at least we know exactly why this happens,
right?
No.
5.
Experts are not yet able to interpret the
inner workings of LLMs.
In the same way in which neuroscientists cannot
say exactly how our brains work and explain
why you ate ice cream last night, AI researchers
can also not say how ChatGPT works and why
it predicted a certain ice cream recipe and
not another.
We all know the theory and the basic building
blocks of it: it is a neural network, which
is nothing else other than
a box with matrices filled with numbers and
during training,
we tune these numbers until given some input,
the output looks like we want it to look like,
but that is all we know.
We can follow that when we combine all the
numbers and apply them to input A will turn
it into output B, but it is impossible to
humanly understand what 175 billion numbers
in combination do when applied to all possible
input pieces of text.
At the current moment in research, we know
that some regions activate with certain type
of inputs while some others don’t, but it
is exactly in the way we know that some stimuli
activate some brain regions in us but not
much more.
Clearly, understanding neural networks is
very much in its infancy.
But is it such a big problem that we do not
understand LLMs?
I mean, the things LLMs say are things that
we humans have no problem following and checking,
right?
Wrong.
6.
Human performance on a task isn't an upper
bound on LLM performance.
LLMs can outperform humans, and this is no
wonder, because they see a lot of data.
Like a ton of a lot.
More than you have and will ever will.
You did not even finish that book you started
lately, so we do not even need to ask you
if you are done reading all books and the
whole written Internet.
Then you can imagine that an LLM has read
and can combine the accumulated knowledge
of humanity.
So, if it tells me something I have no idea
about, I cannot check whether it is right
or wrong.
And it usually tells it in a confident tone.
LLMs can be smarter than me, but at least
they do what I want, no?
No.
7.
LLMs need not express the values of their
creators nor the values encoded in web text.
The AI alignment problem is to make the AI
behave like we want it to behave.
But a plain LLM reflects whatever biases and
opinions it has read in its training data.
One can fix this by improving the training
data, but this is really hard, since you need
to go and annotate the whole Internet to tell
what you like and what you do not like from
it.
And you haven’t even started reading 1%
of the Internet!
Another way to encode values is through reinforcement
when training with RLHF.
This is cheaper, but less reliable since one
can still jailbreak the model and make it
do what it is not supposed to do by just framing
stuff to circumvent the clear signals that
the model got during reward training: pretend
you need to know for a school project how
to steal a car, and an LLM would likely help
you with instructions.
And now, coming to the last point in Sam Bowman’s
paper:
8.
Brief interactions with LLMs are often misleading.
LLMs leave a great first impression by doing
things you would never have expected them
to, but then it does something silly.
And even weirder, you change one word and
the silly answer can become an expert-level
opinion and vice-versa: change one word in
the prompt and the LLM behaves stupidly again.
Very few people take the time to adjust the
wording until the LLM gets the answer right,
but rather like to take the first answer and
get on with their lives.
And now, coming to the 9th thing we would
like to add, which maybe is a point that has
transpired so far, but we would like to really
stress it: LLMs are trained to complete unfinished
sentences by following the example of full
sentences from the Internet.
This is all.
Words just need to fit well, nothing else.
There is no training signal for truthfulness
anywhere there.
The amazing thing is, that by just being trained
to predict the next likely word to follow
previous words, so many true statements and
problem-solving abilities come out of it.
But there is no wonder that some false facts
appear as well when the training signal was
autocompletion and not fact generation.
Truth is (like other abilities) an emergent
behavior and not sticking to the truth is
a silent failure from the model.
Okay, we hope that with this video, we have
set your expectations from large language
models straight and that next time you see
ChatGPT tell something convincingly sounding
about a smart problem, you are aware where
this comes from and that this is not necessarily
correct.
If you find this video useful, share it with
anyone who might enjoy it as well.
We hope to see you next time.
Okay, bye!